this video is sponsored by raycon
in preparation for robert pattinson's
new batman film today i will be
reviewing every live-action batman movie
from the 20th century yup that's right
all of them i don't know anything about
batman this has been one of the most
difficult videos i've ever made and i'm
about to show you all how batman changed
from this
into this
so before i collapse from exhaustion
let's review every live-action batman
film from 1966 all the way to 1997. this
is my review of classic batman please
for the love of god
subscribe as some of you might remember
in december and january i reviewed every
live-action spider-man film i'd been a
spider-man fan since before i could
remember and due to that i was able to
rely on a base level of knowledge i had
concerning the character however when it
comes to batman i have quite literally
less of an idea about him than most
people in the world i have never read
any of the comics watched any of the old
tv shows any of the animated series or
the vast majority of the film save for
two i did see the dark knight in
theaters for a friend's birthday and i
saw batman v superman on a complete whim
with my ex-girlfriend and neither of us
had a good time and well you see that's
kind of a problem because i have to
review all of these films how can i
write a review if i have no idea who the
character is and by proxy have no idea
if the portrayal of the batman in these
films are accurate and speak to the
essence of that character well the
answer is i couldn't review them and so
it seemed i needed some help enter aj
you're a big guy for you aj is a massive
batman fan and compiled for me a list of
the most fundamental and critically
acclaimed batman comics for me to read
and so i did my homework and in my
studies something came to my attention
batman undergoes a change a considerably
large and fundamental change in the
1980s following the initial flamboyant
and goofy run from 1939 all the way up
to the 1970s unlike the more modern
interpretations of the character the
majority of the golden and silver age
otherwise known as the pre-70s material
is largely disconnected formatted as a
series of self-contained one-off issues
and as a result there weren't really any
story arcs for me to sink my teeth into
which stands in direct contrast to what
i have available for me today nowadays
the batman brand is as iconic or perhaps
even more iconic than that of superman
in some cases however back in the 1960s
this wasn't the case in fact superman
would routinely sell far more comics
yuri than batman would at the turn of
the decade in 1960 batman was the sixth
best-selling comic the following year it
was the seventh and by 1965 superman
stood atop the comic book world all the
while batman had slipped down to ninth
place behind the likes of archie and
three separate superman spin-offs with
the likes of superboy superman's
girlfriend lois lane and superman's pal
jimmy olsen selling far more copies than
batman that year let me repeat
superman's pal jimmy olsen sold 100 000
more copies than batman in 1965. i mean
i have no idea jimmy olsen could be a
really cool character and i don't even
know
however this was all about to change for
on january 12 1966 a show so amazing so
influential and more iconic than
anything the mcu has released to date
would hit the screens of millions of
homes across the united states and
indeed the rest of the world i am of
course alluding to the single greatest
children's tv show of all time adam
west's batman
following its release batman received an
enormous boost in pop culture appeal and
by july of that same year batman
received his very first live action
flick and in all seriousness it might be
one of the funniest movies i've ever in
my life seen
batman 1966 the 1966 adam west batman
film is a cavalcade of wackiness that
quite literally defined the term camp
when applied to superhero film turning
any and all apparent theatrical or
ostentatiousness from the original
comics run all the way up to 11. this
film is bonkers with a capital silent q
i know i normally break down these kinds
of films based on their narrative or
creative merits but i feel like doing so
with this film would do a disservice to
this magnificent work of art and indeed
all of you for instance the first 10
minutes of this film acts as a quick
introduction to what exactly we'll be
getting ourselves into for the following
104 minutes it does not pull its punches
in being exactly what you might think it
is we get a pole to the batcave that
dresses them up in their iconic albeit
cheap looking crime-fighting costumes we
have the batmobile which produces fire
out the back that clearly isn't doing
anything there's the back copter which
is clearly a regular helicopter with bat
paraphernalia haphazardly strewn across
it and to my surprise we even get a
fleeting glimpse of batman's famed shark
repellent spray which naturally blows up
a shark
now before i go ahead and ignore the
plot of this film for the next three
minutes i'll quickly explain for those
of you who haven't seen this work of art
batman and robin try to stop the riddler
joker catwoman and penguin from doing
something evil for about 104 minutes
with some of the loosest applications of
logic i've ever witnessed in my life
there's a clear and concerted effort
made to make this some of the most
harmless television available while also
trying to deal with romantic
relationships kidnapping entanglements
hostage situations and a host of other
incredible circumstances for instance a
little over halfway through this film in
an effort to surprise attack batman
penguin dehydrates his minions into dust
and once inside the bat cave rehydrates
them however something goes wrong with
even the slightest touch the rehydrated
minions flash out of existence and the
following is batman's explanation for
what just happened i quote whoever
dehydrated those pirates could not have
foreseen their accidental rehydration
with the heavy water we used which
naturally left them in a highly unstable
condition the slightest impact was
sufficient enough to reduce them to
antimatter antimatter you mean they
won't be coming back batman and to that
adam west delivers one of the most
sobering line deliveries in all of film
no robin
not in this universe
i think part of what makes this film so
incredible and weird to me isn't how
crazily it's written or even how every
performance is more over the top and
sillier than the last but it's adam
west's almost deadpan performance of
batman it sincerely feels as though he's
treating this as if he's in line for an
oscar he has the strangest performance
and delivery i've ever seen from any
actor in this film and this is the film
with mickey from the rocky films dressed
as a penguin man and caesar romero as
the joker clearly putting makeup over
his very pronounced mustache now on a
more serious note apart from the obvious
visual flamboyance that colored the
screen during this picture what i found
most interesting about the film and
indeed the adam west batman character
was how it came into existence with the
batman comic book and character having
been released during the years of the
second world war batman and superman
comics were both vehicles of escapism
for a growing population of people in
north america and this was felt all over
the entertainment industry back in the
40s and 50s with a lot of the focus
placed on producing live-action war
inspired films and tv shows however by
the time the 50s were coming to an end
and the 60s were on the horizon a lot of
different studios began investing into
crime fighting or horror based shows
such as the still somewhat popular adams
family the network abc was struggling at
the time and needed their quote adam's
family if they were to future-proof
their station and looked into comic
books for a solution and their first
choice was
it was superman i mean of course it was
superman was one of the most popular
comics at the time however the rights of
superman were otherwise entangled in
something else a superman musical which
sounds like the best worst idea i've
ever heard needless to say it eliminated
that option for abc which brought us to
the second choice they had which was
dick tracy a comic strip about a good
guy cop trying to stop bad guys and once
again the rights weren't available and
so abc went with their third choice
batman and robin and when it came to
finding the best man to play the role of
batman charles fitzsimmons associate
producer for the show said it was a
tough search for actors because you had
to find an actor who was prepared to
play alice in wonderland as though it
were hamlet however they eventually
found their golden boy and after having
scouted him by way of a nestle
commercial of all places adam west end
up becoming a magnificent fit for their
vision of the hokey and over-the-top
batman character we know and love today
from that tv series and movie following
the roaring success batman enjoyed
courtesy of what i am now calling the
adam west effect in 1966 batman's comics
too enjoyed tremendous success with the
general public routinely besting even
superman's sales in the years 1966 and
1967 overall selling more copies than
any other property in north america
however this wasn't all good news in the
eyes of batman's longtime fans with the
show having been created by a person by
the name of william dozier a man that
seemed to detest the very concept of
comic books
and so authenticity to the source
material wouldn't have been something
that would have been high in his
priority list and thus the show we know
and loved today was produced and before
i continue there's a brilliant video
chronicling the journey of adam west
batman over the channel on nerdsync if
you're interested in the topic i'll
leave the link in the description but in
as he says while reflecting on the
vision the fans at the time had on the
property the show turned batman who was
a serious literary character into a
national laughingstock the dark knight
was hip and popular across the country
because he was presented as a joke the
television series defiled their batman
and even their comic books weren't safe
from the adam west effect holy ravioli
slowly as the years trickled on by and
batman comics flew off the shelves the
over-the-top catch phrases from robin
such as holy holy holy batman would make
their way into the comics as well as the
over-the-top encounters in imagery
however after the tv show concluded on
march 14 1968 so too did batman's reign
at the top of the comic book world with
batman continuing to fall in popularity
as the years march forward into the next
decade it seemed as though the world's
idea of batman had been marred in the
eyes of many lifelong fans by this
looney-tuned version of the dark knight
however as the 70s marched onwards into
the 80s it became apparent that the once
flamboyant and colorful characters that
decorated the screens of the comic books
in the 1940s 50s and 60s wouldn't cut it
for audiences with a more modern
sensibility and so it was at this time a
decision was made to reinvent the
character of batman in a fashion we had
never before seen with a much more
grizzled adult and realistic approach
which thankfully led to the creation of
1987's batman year one this is the
quintessential modern origin story for
batman with it serving as the basis for
basically any and all modern
interpretations of the character this
was the very first batman comic i ever
read and it was far more engaging than i
ever expected it to be it's not overly
long has a compelling story with a clear
vision and delivers upon it in an
incredible way with some stunning panel
work and immersive world building and
while i loved adam west batman it was
through this story i really felt as
though i began to understand who and
what batman truly was and this very
comic's influence was not only felt in
the comic book industry but through
every subsequent batman film to be
released from that point onward starting
with batman 1989. hello everyone and
welcome to the very first batman film i
can actually review as a film and not as
a meme between the years of 1978 and
1987 superman once again led the way on
the big screen with feature film success
with the first film entitled superman
grossing a massive 300 million dollars
at the box office however with superman
2 superman 3 and even superman 4
producing increasingly disappointing
results of the box office it seemed that
the culture among young americans of the
time were shifting from the uplifting
and bright to something a little more
gritty and it would appear that a
certain character that had recently been
the recipient of a major overhaul was
now primed for a spectacular worldwide
release
tim burton and michael keaton's batman
set the world ablaze upon its release
and marked a pivotal moment in the genre
of superhero films taking home well over
400 million dollars at the box office it
was clear that the world was ready for
more batman but was the movie any good i
don't know let's take a look [ __ ]
batman alright so i went ahead and
watched both of the tim burton films and
boy do i have some opinions in short i
liked the 1989 version well enough i
enjoyed keaton's aloof and charming
performance as batman and nicholson did
a tremendously unique and entertaining
job portraying the clown prince of crime
however it was the second one that
really impressed me and i can't wait to
explain why in just a second so let's
talk about the first of these two films
to kick this off from a visual and lore
standpoint i can see some similarities
with burton's imagery and the year one
material and certainly the origin of
batman which bookends this film i also
enjoyed how the first time we see
keaton's batman he's positioned and
written to strike fear into the hearts
of gotham's criminal underworld this too
is incredibly close to the comics in
spirit particularly the entrances he
makes through the smoke furthermore and
this is an aspect of the story i really
liked the film loves to bask in bruce's
lavish lifestyle however not just for
the sake of it but to instead drive home
a point to us watching that his living
situation is deeply depressing dark and
lonely highlighted specifically through
a dinner date scene which moves from a
big dark room on a long table to a much
cozier and intimate setting alongside
alfred his only family left in the world
it's a nice short scene that grants us a
glimpse into the life of bruce wayne and
this is an aspect of the film i wish
they leaned more on there is of course
some great stuff concerning his past
within protecting a family to kick off
the film and his leaving of two roses
where his parents died but i wish we got
more of that in this film seeing as it's
his debut feature i'm batman jack
nicholson's joker is quite different and
much more human than the comics
depiction nicholson really does make it
his own though and he's got the perfect
face for it that smile is truly the
stuff of nightmares nicholson's joker
runs a crime syndicate and in the middle
of a heist they get cut off by the cops
and batman before forcing him to fall
off into chemicals and in the process
the joker is born something i wasn't
really a fan of however with burton's
joker was how much we actually got to
learn about him personally in the comics
he's much more of an agent of chaos a
mystery a calculated lunatic running
amok and one of my favorite aspects of
the joker is how much of a mystery he is
hypothetically if the origin we see
removes that mystique from the character
then all that's left is a comparatively
less interesting character in my opinion
as a result burton's joker to me at
least felt far more human and dare i say
flawed in an understandable and human
sort of way with that said however
nicholson's depiction is utterly
chilling with cartoonish music
juxtaposing the more gruesome and
grotesque acts he commits his laugh
wheezes not unlike nails on a chalkboard
with a bassy whisper that's as grinding
as a growl the elements he brings to
this performance are uniquely his own
creation as is the character largely
which i think plays a big part as to why
he's so fondly remembered today it's a
fittingly unsettling and cartoonish
performance that i was very much a fan
of
unlike the comics i was surprised and
sort of disappointed with how small a
role commissioner gordon played in this
feature in batman year one gordon is one
of the two main characters he delivers
and is responsible for a large amount of
the criminal exposition the culture
within the police force and indeed
gotham at large in this film however
that exposition is largely facilitated
by a character i'm not too familiar with
called vicki vale performed by kim
bassinger i personally found this
character and performance to be
relatively dull in comparison to other
supporting characters we'll be sure to
get on to in the next film one thing
though that did take me off guard with
this film was its incredible soundtrack
courtesy of none other than danny elfman
if you haven't seen these films this is
the man responsible for scoring the
raimi spider-man trilogy and having
never seen this movie i wondered myself
why i had heard this music before and
then realized it too was present in
batman the animated series while i was
growing up which again i didn't really
watch though it was on from time to time
i have taken off my makeup
let's see
if you can take off yours
overall i liked this film but i wouldn't
say i loved it the performance from jack
nicholson was fun and entertaining often
times carrying the feature during the
more energetic moments through extreme
exaggerated poses and even dancing that
said keaton delivered a very good batman
performance as well with an appropriate
level of charm and cool factor to help
sell the part effectively i did think
that the supporting characters at the
newspaper were intensely boring at times
and the action sequences fell
surprisingly flat for me though the
batmobile and other such bad accessories
were appropriately cool to see in action
i think i'll largely chalk down the
stilted action to the clearly very
restrictive neck on the bat suit and so
in closing if a 5 out of 10 is a meh
score i'd say this one lands at a 6 or a
6.5 out of 10 for me i liked it but i
thought there were a few moments where i
felt the film really showed its age
which it's allowed to do this was after
all one of the first films to blaze a
trail for the current superhero films
released today so without further ado
let's move on to the sequel that really
surprised me yeah but first a quick word
from our sponsor if you're in the market
for new wireless earbuds that offer the
same sound quality as premium brands at
half the price then raycon's everyday
earbuds are exactly what you need they
look sound and most importantly feel
better than ever each pair comes with
their fantastic optimized gel tips that
give you the perfect in-ear fit i use
these while i exercise all the time so
trust me when i say not only are they
super comfortable but they will not come
out of your ears even during the most
intense sessions i've spoken in the past
about how rarely i need to charge them
but it cannot be overstated with 8 hours
of constant play time and a total of 32
hours of battery life they're always
ready to go when you need them and it's
no wonder they've become so popular
these earbuds have over 48 000 five-star
reviews and it's easy to see why with a
45-day happiness guarantee you can try
them totally risk-free but honestly you
won't need it they're great so if you're
interested in hearing for yourself click
the link in the description box or go to
buy recon dot com forward slash not mark
to get 15 off your recon order
batman returns alright we're here in
1992. i'm one year old i can't speak in
full sentences yet and this film gets
released fast forward 30 years and i
find myself watching it now and my god
did i think this one was better than the
last while i enjoyed batman in this
sequel and found penguin to be much more
enjoyable than the joker from 1989 i
will say that by far what carried this
film for me was michelle pfeiffer's
portrayal of selena kyle's catwoman what
a stunningly entertaining performance
from her and a brilliant depiction from
timber totally perfect for this film
[Music]
in preparation for this movie i read up
a little on the penguin and catwoman's
comic counterparts as they both played
pivotal roles in this flick for the
penguin i read a short story from the
first issue of joker's asylum narrated
by the joker this short comic offered
valuable insight into the more cerebral
aspects of the penguin's psyche and
illuminated why he's one of batman's
most fearsome adversaries i should also
mention that there is a critical
difference between this modern
incarnation of the character and the
pre-70s era version which depicted a fat
man armed with an umbrella performing
goofy somersaults in this short comic i
discovered the crippling adolescence
that transformed oswald couple pot a
young boy yearning to feel accepted into
the penguin we see today a crime boss
plagued by a deep sense of inferiority
and contempt for those that would dare
laugh at or ridicule him i very much
enjoyed the character and thus was
interested in seeing how tim burton
would handle him in addition to
researching penguin as i mentioned i
looked into catwoman too for her i was
told to read batman year one which i did
and perhaps more helpful than that was
catwoman went in wrong a comic published
in 2005 that works as a great follow-up
to another comic dark victory which i'll
reference later on for
batman and robin but for now catwoman
when in rome acts as my framework for
what catwoman ought to be like as a
character and my god does michelle
pfeiffer knock it out of the park and
while i'm talking about both catwoman
and penguin respectively i think an
interesting component to this narrative
is that both of these characters are
both shunned by society to varying
degrees and encouraged to stay small and
hidden away in their respective corners
either psychologically or directly take
penguin for example cast away into the
sewers by his aristocratic pair and
shocked by his deformities oswald is
saved and raised by penguins underneath
the gotham zoo and once the time is
right he makes his presence known in
more ways than one however this aspect
of exploring shunned souls is
particularly apparent through catwoman
specifically selena kyle a meek
secretary to an evil abusive man her
input laughed at her demeanor demure and
her prospects limited however she
experiments with increasingly more
unhinged and extreme actions starting
off with something minor and eventually
graduates to full-blown murder as she
expresses the full extent of her
autonomy onto the city that kept her
subservient i want to speak more on
these two in just a sec but i didn't do
this with the last film so i have to do
it now can we talk about tim burton for
just a second if you thought tim
burton's artistic stylings were
perfectly apparent in the first film
then this one will straight up assault
your senses with the burton ness on
display having broken box office records
with his outing on batman 1989 this film
more than shows how his confidence as a
creative has grown now i'm not an expert
on mr bird by any stretch of the
imagination but hey i like the nightmare
before christmas and beetlejuice so i'll
give it a shot while i was in art school
tim burton was someone i looked up to
quite a lot not necessarily in terms of
style though i did think it was very
cool but more so in terms of philosophy
looking through his sketchbooks from his
schooling and college years it's clear
to see that this style we all know and
associate with burton today was alive
and well inside his brain long before he
even made a theatrical release he never
felt compelled to be anything else other
than himself and when i as well as
hundreds of other artists had clear
visual inspirations for her work that
all looked very similar it was really
cool to see an artist that naturally
stood out from everyone his dedication
to exaggerated proportions haunting and
gaunt expressions and intense shadows
having permeated his earliest work all
the way through to today and this batman
sequel was no different while it was
abundantly clear who produced this film
in 89 with its intense use of shadows
moody set dressing and predilection for
uncomfortably distorted camera shots i
did feel as though there was a certain
level of restraint being applied here
like he was afraid to fully commit to
something which wasn't his own having
only produced one film prior to this
that felt intensely burdened i suspect
that following the tremendous success of
the first batman film he may have felt
as though he had earned the right to
enjoy a freedom of expression with this
one and so cue the gross imagery gangly
proportions grotesque shots and
returning now more intense than ever are
the pitch black shadows and smoke that
cloak this world of gotham this first
act of the film is great it establishes
two primary villains penguin and shrek
with the latter's plan to not distribute
energy across gotham but to instead suck
the power from the city in order to
bring it to its knees and therefore
depend highly on him but interestingly
there's very little bruce wayne and
batman in this film's first 45 minutes
outside of a brief fight scene within
which the batmobile does most of the
fighting i'm not knocking that aspect of
the film by the way i just found it
interesting that said i do like that
there seems to be equal parts dedicated
for bruce to flex some of his
investigative strengths in trying to
come to grips with what in fact is going
on danny devito's portrayal of the
penguin is horrifyingly brilliant and
there are a few scenes where i felt they
matched the comics nicely and certainly
more than nicholson's joker did once
again a man manipulated by society
forced to be something that he's not in
order to get something he should have
had from the beginning a sense of
belonging going about getting what he
lost or feels like he's owed in all the
wrong ways we can understand him but not
justify what he's doing and while there
are obvious differences between this
penguin and the one we saw in the comics
unlike nicholson's great albeit unique
portrayal of the joker this performance
from devito really stays true to the
spirit of the modern penguin character i
felt particularly during this scene with
shrek as he tries to convince him into
becoming mayor of gotham in order to
help leverage and elevate his own
position the final act of this film is
fittingly silly in nature with penguin
fixing all of the various species of
penguin in his possession with
explosives to destroy the city of gotham
however alfred of all peoples sends them
all back to the sewers saving the city
so in short alfred kind of saves more
people than batman across all of these
films now before i move on to batman
forever i want to dedicate some time to
michelle pfeiffer's catwoman here
catwoman is by far and away the single
best part of this film i think i enjoyed
michael keaton's inoffensive portrayal
of batman he has plenty of charming
moments and i think he plays the role
quite well when compared to the comics
danny devito's penguin i think is even
better with his physical appearance
being morphed by burton's tastes so
perfectly and his motivations and
dialogue so in keeping with the
penguin's character however michelle
pfeiffer's catwoman is the 10 out of 10
chef's kiss performance that carried
this film for me from the very first
time she hits her collective screen she
holds her attention tightly in her claws
i thought long and hard about why i felt
more of a connection to and interest
towards her than any other character in
these films and eventually the answer
became clear to me of all the main
characters in these films batman joker
penguin so much of what drives them are
outside forces leading them to becoming
reactionary characters why does batman
get involved well because he's reacting
to the joker penguin or other such
villains committing crimes why did joker
act well it was partially to do with him
wanting to get revenge and partially out
of jealousy towards batman and why did
penguin act the way he acted because of
the contempt he had for the world who
shunned him he opened himself up and
would react to the manipulations of
catwoman the jeers of the city and
eventually the actions of batman but
catwoman's entire character here is
about freedom she consciously skirts and
flirts with the line dividing villain
and antihero all the while being exactly
what she wasn't at the beginning an
autonomous active agent in her own life
and this film once upon a time she did
not live for herself at the beginning of
this film were greeted by a woman
subservient to an employer that
belittles her when we see where she
lives we're reminded constantly how her
social and familial life is being
stripped away from her because she feels
beholden to others however when she
becomes catwoman she becomes her own
hero someone that exacts her own agency
over the plot she very rarely reacts to
what others do and when she does it's a
pivotal moment that catches her off
guard as well as everyone else in the
scene and following those moments her
composure visibly shakes instead in this
film she almost always acts out of her
own self-interest driven by her desire
to please herself in the moment
instigating much of the plot by way of
the penguin and various other encounters
at the very end of the film she ends up
killing her former employer in
spectacular fashion she's been betrayed
by society and despite batman's best
suggestions for what the correct course
of action should be here she ignores him
she's in control of her own destiny and
does what she wants she's not taking
orders from anyone anymore playing into
the nine lives of the cat trope
absorbing bullets all the while reciting
the children's rhyme staggering closer
and closer until however a kiss santy
claus
using the weapon she took from her
attacker at the start of the film the
moment that signified her first step
into doing something for herself she
takes out the person she once served in
devastatingly psychotic fashion well i
do think this film is far sillier and
perhaps a little bit more stilted on a
narrative level particularly when you
consider how little batman actually has
to do with this story catwoman is still
an unbelievably fun character and the
best in this film and to be clear that's
really not to take from the other
fantastic performances here it is just
to say that in my opinion she elevates
this film far higher than it otherwise
would have been without her i mean
there's a scene where her character has
to hold a bird in her mouth and when
watching it i thought that was a fake
bird but when i watched the behind the
scenes it turns out that this was a very
real bird and michelle pfeiffer shot
that scene several times for several
takes she held a bird a real bird in her
mouth michelle pfeiffer in this role i
believe is unmatched careful yet
reckless driven by instinct yet playful
just as cats do
meow
batman forever
well
this is different
what the hell happened
is what i can imagine a large number of
people thought when the marketing for
this film kicked into high gear new
actors new director knew everything this
was the very first of the batman films i
remember being advertised to me while i
was a kid i think i had some vhs tapes
with the ad for it at the beginning and
remember vhs tapes couldn't escape the
ads even then needless to say after what
i thought was the best batman so far in
batman returns i was so surprised they
changed the approach so completely that
i had to do some research to discover
why and i found out why was the answer
satisfying no not really do i kind of
understand it though yeah for sure when
my dad brought me to see spider-man 1 in
2002 he did so with the expectation that
this was a superhero flick and therefore
a film for children and while it was
great for children it was also something
that he could enjoy much to his surprise
during the early 90s however superhero
films very much had that stigma seen
predominantly as films to be geared
towards a younger demographic with
advertising tie-ins to fast food chains
and of course merchandising galore these
were massive revenue streams for these
films and as a result a lot of time was
dedicated to advertising the films prior
to their release through these channels
can i persuade you to take a sandwich
with you sir i'll get drive-through i'll
get drive-through that's the first
actual line in the movie and it's there
exclusively to serve as this ad for
mcdonald's but i digress following the
release of batman returns while there
was a considerable amount of praise for
that film warner brothers the rights
holders for the film and the ones who
make all the decisions including
overseeing direction and scripting they
made an oopsy you see remember when in
batman returns we have the hyper
sexualized selena kyle some light body
horror through penguin penguin biting
someone so hard they bleed from their
face and of course at the very end where
he bleeds from his mouth and then dies
yeah remember all that [ __ ] up stuff
yeah well that was a film that was
advertised towards children too and as a
result warner brothers were the
recipient of some unsavory calls from
disgruntled parents with that said
however the film was labeled pg-13 in
the states and 15s where i'm from so i
think it's kind of the parent's fault
personally batman returns wasn't the
two-hour toy advertisement warner
brothers were expecting and despite
burton being eager to sign on for
another film to complete his trilogy or
to at least get a trilogy he also felt
as though his vision was no longer
welcomed there and so signed on as a
producer instead for the next film with
warner brothers looking to gear the next
installment specifically towards younger
kids and as a result hired mr joel
schumacher to direct the resulting
script was enough to push michael keaton
away from the project with him claiming
that the script quote sucked and in
response to that glowing endorsement val
kilmer signed on to take up the mantle's
batman and bruce wayne and what followed
was a film with aspects i liked and
aspects i really did like to prepare for
this i read up on a few new characters
that this film introduced to me the
riddler and robin i began by reading a
comic called four of a kind for edward
bigma's riddler through that i learned a
great deal concerning his childhood
revealing his motivating factors his
insecurities and his traumas then
finally i discovered dick grayson
otherwise known as robin dark victory
was the comic i read to come to grips
with who he was and what he represents
for the character of batman 2. two-face
is in this film technically but i just
really hated tommy lee jones's two-face
here i've seen the dark knight and to be
honest i prefer to give my impression on
the character of two-face and harvey
dent in that film for obvious reasons
and besides we have plenty to talk about
in this one alright so what are my
thoughts on this film well i can imagine
that for many out there it's a pretty
divisive one loved and hated by many in
equal measure i can totally see children
watching this film and getting a great
kick out of it the fight sequences are a
lot more out there and experimental if
not very silly the set pieces and set
designs were massively different clearly
demonstrating a ton of different
iconography and time having been put
into them particularly when it comes to
the character of edward nigma the
riddler who i kind of loved in this and
i feel like that might be a
controversial statement but then again
it does make sense because there are
plenty out there who find this era of
jim carrey plenty annoying personally
this era of gym in the early 90s was the
only aspect of this film that i felt a
connection to on a nostalgic level and
there i think is where the reasons lie
for my take on this if you have
nostalgia for this film then i can well
imagine you having a great time with it
well enough however when you're like me
and you're seeing it for the very first
time in your 30s then it's a bit of an
acid trip coming off the back of batman
returns jim carrey's performance as the
riddler is a crazy combination of his
ace ventura character combined with the
cable guy the latter of which i enjoyed
but not many other people did regardless
carrie really throws himself into this
role and without him i think i would
have had a much more difficult time
watching this movie the edward digma
character is handled a little
heavy-handedly for my liking by the
script however with eddie's first scene
effectively talking his character's
motivations to us on screen in place of
a more natural starting point showing us
his admiration for bruce instead but i
did enjoy his deep-rooted sense of
inferiority and desperation to be
noticed for the genius he believed
himself to be with his living quarters
reflecting that very aspect of his
persona a crazy amount of work and
energy tucked away in a small narrow
room under-appreciated and underutilized
just like how he feels furthermore i
think i liked carrie in this as much as
i did because of how this film is made
too everything looks like a toy or a
cartoon at times brought to life which
can be a good or a bad thing depending
on your tastes and while tommy lee jones
looks like he's either phoning it in or
trying way too hard jim carrey the
living cartoon himself really hits the
sweet spot i think for what this film
was trying to achieve and speaking of
tommy lee jones as a quick aside
apparently during the filming of this
movie tommy lee really didn't like jim
carrey great i went over and i said hey
tommy how you doing like that and the
blood just drained from his face
switching gears and speaking on the
robin character for just a sec i will
say that this movie really killed any
and all sense of drama and atmosphere i
felt with the robin character well-read
and just a little wild
oh
if only someone could tame him and
funnily enough they kept it far closer
to the original when telling his story
than i thought they would too in the
original robin is part of a circus act
as the flying grayson's family of
acrobats who get caught up as collateral
damage from an organized criminal attack
causing their equipment to malfunction
leading to them falling to their
respective deaths of the family robin is
the sole survivor and bruce seeing
himself in robin's suffering takes him
under his wing and guardianship to help
him avoid the life he ended up leading
that's a wonderful dynamic and while
it's technically here the fashion with
which it's carried out is odd and that's
the charitable reading of the events
there's less of a tragic atmosphere and
more of a loony and cartoonish one in
the comics we were bathing in a more
harrowing and tragic occasion whereas
this uses it as a means with which to
link the riddler and two-face together
while forcing dick grayson the robin
character to contend with a comically
sized bomb and while it leads to the
same relationship between batman and
robin the age of dick in this film
played by a 25 year old chris o'donnell
again makes the occasion feel less akin
to bruce's experience as robin at this
point is a grown ass man and if that
didn't ruin the character robin is hyper
annoying both in this film and certainly
the next which is a shame i thought
because one of the few criticisms i had
for the prior films was that i wish
they'd spent more time exploring the
traumas and backstory of the main
character bruce wayne the foundations of
that character are precisely why he does
what he does and it's that motivation
that makes him such an interesting
character when grappling with the
morality of his violent actions in
addition to wondering if he could or
should take lesser or more extreme steps
in order to prevent further harm on
other individuals he's totally unlike
superman and spider-man and it's that
flavor which is explored in this film
specifically behind the thick layer of
cheese toy commercials and product
placements is a story i could have
really sunk my teeth into and apparently
there was a cut of this film which was
45 minutes longer and one could assume
contained within it were parts of the
actual storytelling that didn't hold any
value on a merchandising level for the
studio but held a considerable amount of
narrative importance or significance for
the plot to enrich it alas we shall
never know i'm only now realizing by the
way that i never gave my score out of 10
for batman returns so let's say i give
it a 7 or a 7.5 i really enjoyed that
film thanks predominantly to catwoman
this film however i'd be more inclined
to give a 4 out of 10. the film overall
is wacky in a charming but mostly
intrusive way the most irritating
characters by far are two-faced followed
shortly after by robin neither at any
point past the vibe check with tommy lee
jones being the standout failure of this
picture in my opinion i enjoyed the
riddler for what he was and thought he
should have been the sole villain in
this story and the biggest surprise was
that val kilmer's batman i kinda liked
him despite the cringy script overall
the film has some interesting and
ambitious ideas with regards the various
characters they demonstrated but the
modern incarnations of these characters
are built upon much more realistic
foundations than what this film and the
studio felt comfortable with exploring
or bringing to life interested more in
creating a living cartoon for children
than an engaging story that while
faithful to the comics would also
capture the minds of both young and old
alike and with the next film instead of
trying to find a happy medium between
batman returns and batman forever in
terms of tone we got a happy medium
between batman forever and absolute
insanity i introduce you to 1997
batman and robin all right so uh look
1997's batman and robin scored a flaccid
12 on rotten tomatoes secured a 238
million box office against a 160
million dollar budget and is widely
considered one of the worst superhero
films ever made if there's anybody
watching this and went into batman and
robin with great anticipation if i if i
disappointed them in any way
then i really want to apologize to be
clear we are talking about a film that
performs so poorly and receives such a
bad reception that warner brothers
cancelled their next batman film
entitled batman unchained and instead
settled for rebooting the series in 2005
with batman begins and the nolan trilogy
and i can see why didn't you apologize
to the crowd at comic-con for batman and
robin i always apologize for that
speaking as someone that started this
video with virtually no basis or
knowledge of the batman series and spend
countless hours researching reading
watching and writing about them over the
last month so that i can apply it to
these films i can safely say that for
this film it has been an enormous waste
of my time for example poison ivy is a
character that plays a leading role in
this film and in preparation for her i
dedicated some time to try to figure her
out by consuming this short but
brilliant comic from 1986 called poison
ivy secret origins this was the comic
that redefined the character from her
campy golden age era persona into the
tragic heroine she's known as today and
furthermore this is a comic book that
understands and has a passion for the
character written by someone that could
take the perspective of a convicted
murderer of a psychopath and accurately
and charitably convey her perspective
for us not only to understand but also
connect with like check out this page
for example on this page our point of
view character steward asks poison ivy
why she's chosen her name to be poison
ivy the name of a weed when she herself
admits to having a passion for all
things botanical her response is concise
but illuminates so much about her as a
character she says there's no such thing
as a weed a weed is just a plant some
human decides is growing in the wrong
place
what an outstanding life this is what it
looks like when a writer is talented and
cares about these characters it's why we
look to passionate people online for
their takes on these things they love
because through these people we can see
these stories and characters in a new
light and none of that nuance or
interest is in this movie instead we get
bat nipples and close-ups of george
clooney's perfect ass and speaking of
george clooney one upsetting thing about
this film for me was that george clooney
was in the role of batman and not
because i don't like george clooney i'm
actually a fan of his work the
descendants and fantastic mr fox are
great films in their own right and oh
brother where art though happens to be
one of my favorite films of all time so
let me be clear i like me some clooney
but this script is not only broken on a
narrative level but totally misses the
point of batman's character that the
last film managed to get right to some
extent so in short this film makes me
hate george i always apologize for that
any hint of struggle or trauma behind
batman's eyes have been replaced by some
cheeky smirks and about 30 different dad
jokes if there's anything this last
month of reading and studying batman has
taught me it's that following the
facelift the series received in the 80s
all the best characters in the story are
ones rooted in or tangentially connected
to some sort of personal trauma batman
poison ivy dick grayson riddler catwoman
penguin heck the only one who isn't
directly tied to a trauma is the joker
and something must have happened to that
dude for him to turn out the way that he
was this is a story rooted in reality
and dark subject matter and this film
threw all of that out the window in
favor of what killed the dinosaurs
the ice age
iceman was an utter disaster of a
character and shared no resemblance to
his comic or animated series
counterparts for that matter reduced to
a single muscle-bound overly glitzy
laughable series of ice puns and look i
know this movie was geared towards
children but through iceman's ice
capades in this movie all it did was
leave me isolated as a viewer but look
it's no problem and okay i would try to
cram one more ice bun in here but it
slipped my mind so let's move on unlike
the prior film where i had my issues but
was able to find some positives this
film strips the story of any semblance
of weight or value for me it makes
batman worse dick grayson even more
annoying and filled itself with villains
that are either insulting or intolerable
and this film technically has bane by
the way a character that's supposed to
be a genius in both body and mind
someone that's famous for being the one
who broke the bat in both body and
spirit not some mindless zombie that's
pumped full of weird steroid stuff i
can't imagine what this film must have
been like for fans of batman back in the
day but right here and right now i'm
giving this disaster of a movie one out
of ten i really did not like any part of
this film and that does it those are all
the live-action batman films from before
the millennium quite the journey but
we're not even halfway yet next week i
have seven more films to review catwoman
2004 the nolan trilogy bvs joker and
justice league and my team won't let me
see anything other than the four-hour
schneider cut off the justice league
this is going to be a long week but
until then i've been totally not marked
i hope to see you all there same bad
time same bad place
[Music]
you